.
Je te savais pas que nous dit
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
- Ah-ah! Et un, deux, trois.
- Angie Augustin est sur
un n, , , car elle interprète
une de ses chorégraphies
de style afro dans la version
canadienne de "Just Dance 2023",
un populaire jeu vidéo
d'Ubisoft.
ANGIE AUGUSTIN "CITRON ROSE",
chorégraphe et créa. de contenu
- C'est sûr que c'est un moment
de fierté. C'est un moment
que... Je ne sais pas comment
le décrire tellement c'était
plein d'émotions. Mais j'ai eu
un petit peu les larmes aux yeux
pour être bien honnête.
- L'histoire d'Angie Augustin,
alias Citron Rose,
est inspirante.
Née à Montréal de parents
haïtiens, cette autodictate
a eu la piqûre pour nsnsnsnses
africaines dès le début
de sa vingtaine. Le style
de danse afro, elle en est
devenue obsédée.
- Je cherchais des tutoriels
sur YouTube. Je cherchais
des vidéos statatatagram,
je les enregistrais. Puis,
j'étais comme: OK, ce mouvement-
là, il faut que je le comprenne.
Comment il s'appelle? OK.
J'essayais de trouver des gens
de ce pays-là qui le faisaient.
Je cisisisis les variantes.
J'étais vraiment...
Ça me stimulait tellement
que je voulais vraiment
me perfectionner là-dedans.
♪ Depuis toujours
j'ai été fière de ma peau ♪
- Angie Augustin est aujourd'hui
une des principales danseuses
de la rappeuse Sarahmée.
Aussi créatrice de contenu,
elle compte 650 000 abonnés
sur TikTok. Tout ce succès
a attiré l'attention d'Ubisoft,
pour qui elle a mis
en chorégraphie
"Woman" de Doja Cat.
- J'ai choisi "Woman" de Doja
Cat, parce que, au quotidien,
moi, j'enseigne de l'afro
de type féminin. Donc j'ai
des groupes de femmes, peu
importe leur niveau de danse,
que je réunis, puis je fais
des chorégraphie pour essayer
de booster leur estime personnel
pour essayer de reconnecter
avec leur corps.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La danseuse chorégraphe et
créatrice de contenu est sur
une lancée et elle compte bien
continuer de partager son amour.
- Je me sens vraiment choyée
d'avoir eu cette place,
qu'Ubisoft m'ait donné la place,
de pouvoir indirectement faire
un statement, dans le sens que
je représente un petit peu
la diversité de Montréal.
T'sais, on voit Montréal en
arrière de moi et c'est si beau!
- Mais attention, n'est pas
Angie Augustin qui veut.
Il faudra vous exercer avant
d'atteindre son niveau.
- La chorégraphie, elle est
de niveau de difficile.
Je tiens à préciser.
- Elle est de niveau difficile.
- Vous mc c c c c c c ça, là!
- Mais c'est normal!
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ ♪ ♪